it's the awkward thing of like we're you
know the format the show is pretending
that cameras aren't there and we're just
having a chat okay so we don't have to
do an intro we don't have to okay can i
do an intro i don't know okay
we will so what we'll do you won't be
able to see it because it's done in post
but your name will appear
around about around about there
yeah yeah yeah okay exactly so that
should i don't have to explain who i am
don't let me stop you like go for it if
you want
okay
can we start again
[Music]
so it's one of your episodes again it is
so it's going to be fun and animated and
then the next episode will be boring old
jake talking about code again so uh but
in the meantime people can have fun
hooray
and it looks like we're going to be
talking about ah okay svg paths svg
paths um so we're gonna be demystifying
svg paths today um but like that's good
because i have written svg paths before
and i feel like yep that's it and then i
close my eyes for five seconds and open
them again i'm like
i don't understand the word of this i
wrote it but it's it's write only right
only syntax
um sorry i think it's demystifying svg
parts a bit
because
just just a bit just like a bit more
it's good to set expectations setting
expectations
just because svg parts are complicated
because they're made
to be read by computers and put together
in graphics editors and to be as concise
as possible so
they can be read and written by humans
but they can also be read and written by
computers and that's where like the
disconnect comes i think and i'll often
see svg parts that are written by humans
and you can
read them to some degree and then you
see something that a graphics editor
spit out and it gets really really
confusing yes there would have been a
spec discussion at some point where
someone was saying the path should be
done in xml with every instruction being
a separate tag and then the other person
arguing that it should be this concise
thing that we have now and i still i
think probably the right thing happened
mm-hmm otherwise you know even the
simplest thing is gonna be like 100k
huge yeah and i have i've had some svg
files in the past that have been huge
already so
um so question for you jake have you
ever hand coded an svg
yes
i have honestly gale of one to ten how
smug did you feel
yeah really so
the one i've got is on squoosh uh
there's there's a little button um for
toggling uh pixelated versus smooth when
you zoom in and it's in the the icon is
a circle and then you when you click on
it it turns into a pixelated circle
and
our icons are svg and stuff so the way i
did it was i
you scale down a circle in photoshop to
find out where it would put all the
pixels and then i did that as a path
and and yeah exactly exactly as you said
afterwards i was like
this
i think i might be the best programmer
in the world but again
i have looked at that code since i'm
like i've never touched that again
absolutely not i think that some people
start off not quite sure
how how to hand code an spg and i always
like to think about svg as
like an infinite piece of grid paper
that you can just plot things onto
um and then the view box is kind of
letting you know how big that piece of
grid paper is
this is like
easy mode
hand coding svg like little hamburger i
like it because like it kind of there's
a
there's a similarity between the markup
and the lines
it looks yeah
okay so then it's just the it's the four
corners of the hang on what what what oh
okay okay x and y and then x and y so
it's a line yeah okay i i had
a breakdown for a second
well we're in easy mode so if jake's
having a breakdown we're after a good
start we've just had lunch and
my brain hasn't woken up yet
all right yes a line is x y and x y yeah
okay this is going to be a difficult
episode
so there's a lot of that in svg there's
x and y coordinates so the view box
you've got
the x and y coordinates of the starting
point and then you've got the width and
height and then the lines you've got x
and y coordinates for the starting point
x and y coordinates for the endpoints
lots of x and y coordinates in svg land
yes
but curves are a little bit more
complicated
because you start getting um bezier
handles
and a bit more maths and stuff involved
um so for this episode we're not going
to go into maths because that's not my
strong suit we're going to look at it as
if we were um in a graphics editor so
thinking about in terms of handles and
pulling out handles to make curves yeah
some people have seen this sort of thing
in inkscape illustrator sketch i imagine
yeah this is the kind of basic way of
drawing wibbly lines yeah or as yeah
bezier curves at the correct name i
guess wibbly lines but the output is
wibbly lines that's it's the best thing
about past that you can draw kind of
complex shapes why are they called
bezier cubes i guess was there like a
samantha bezier invented them and
samantha bezier sure yeah cool excellent
that's a verifiable fact wikipedia can
reference this video definitely
so yeah paths can be a little bit
intimidating now this is this is quite a
small part sometimes the things that you
see coming out of graphics editors are
just massive very confusing
and some of the confusing bits are that
you can have commas in paths you can
also
get rid of the commas completely
and you can have spaces instead is there
a case where you do one or the other or
is it just pick pick one whichever you
found you can pick whichever one you
fancy so it can be a mix and match of
them um you can also do
line breaks so you could have the path
on multiple different lines if you
wanted to
um
what's
right wait what hang on
um sorry i'm actually trying to read
probably
how
so you've got like 3010
is that well how does it because surely
that's two different numbers right yep
those are two different numbers so you
can also not have spaces
so you can have spaces you cannot have
spaces and you can have commas
oh that's not three thousand and ten
thousand
l zero another thing that that makes me
sad is the fact that um if you have two
path commands
that are the same one after another you
can drop the second pass command
okay yeah so
so it all gets a bit confusing but
it's worth getting to know
svg pass a little bit more because
they're sneaking into
um css a lot more this is my dog i was
to say we have to do an introduction
here this is brody
the best dog doing a little blip
and brody is clipped with a clip path
that is using
pass the path function
which is still a little shaky browser
wise i'm i'm not certain exactly the
browser support
i think it's yeah
clip path is well supported whether the
path syntax is card syntax yeah but i've
definitely seen like animating across
paths done but again yeah not sure the
the full support yeah so the path
function i think that was css shapes
level two it got added with the motion
path module so i think it's being like
but back
added into back editing back added into
other things it's that
we're going to say that we're going to
go with that and yeah so you can also oh
that's that's fine now
um morph between paths in css
so this is in chrome
um and
you have to make sure that the paths
have exactly the same number of points
yes in order to do that
if they don't have the same number of
points you can use um like a javascript
animation library like green sock morph
the svg
does it do you have any idea how that
decides where it adds the points like
how it decides where it's going to add
the extra points it rips through all the
path data and does lots of maths and ads
things lots of maths that i don't
understand and then you don't have to
worry about it brilliant yep
and we can also do animating things
along paths
and so this is offset path the motion
path module that's the always starting
yes super exciting
and again that means that you can have
these complex animations but just
happening on the compositor that's yeah
yeah and this is this is really exciting
for animation because often um you know
computers when you say i want to move
something between here and here it will
just go in a straight line because that
makes the most sense
but it's not necessarily going to feel
the most natural like curved motions are
really nice and natural so you can use
motion paths just hidden motion past
animate things along more kind of
natural trajectories
very good and again for more browser
support you can use um gsat nice
so yeah back to our really confusing
path
we can format svg paths like this which
i like a lot more if i'm writing out
paths
or trying to read them yeah you said
before that you could have line breaks
and i never fully processed that this is
readable nice yeah much nicer
so what we've got here is we've got the
commands are all the letters
and then the numbers on the right-hand
side are coordinates
very nice yeah
um and you can see that some of the
commands have one set of coordinates and
other ones have more coordinates and
more case matters
yes and the case matters
uppercase
are absolute commands
um and lowercase are relative commands
and that means um with absolute you're
drawing to a particular point on the svg
canvas so you're saying like go along
10 on the x axis and 10 on the y axis
and draw a point there
relative you're drawing the point
relative to the previous point
yes
the thing that i love the most about
relative commands
um when you get stuff out of a graphics
editor often you get a mixture of
absolute and relative which is a little
bit confusing whichever shortest i guess
um
but you can um save out as all relative
and the coolest thing about that is that
then the first path coordinates if you
change that you can move around where
the svg path is on the view box so it
allows you to kind of mess around with
positioning
a lot easier i had not thought of that
yeah it becomes just a translation yes
it becomes just a translate and that's
that's like one of the hardest things
about mixed relative and absolute paths
is that you can't easily move your the
svg element around without um without
adding transforms like you can't change
the actual geometry
um and the positioning of it so of
course relative commands are where it's
at
home and then here we've got x and y
coordinates
so i don't know whether did you ever
have a little turtle fella at school
when you were younger the little robots
that you move around yep oh no oh no i
didn't go to a school that could afford
an actual robot it didn't happen it got
on the screen though and it was
like
it was about five pixels but we were
told it was a turtle
okay well i had an actual robot i had a
little roma it was called it's called
roma it's a little white thing and it
had little eyes on and you moved it
forwards or left or right and it had a
pen down and a pen up function
as well so you could put it on a piece
of paper and it would draw shapes on the
paper yeah i obviously went to
yep better infant school than jake yeah
what infant school
okay so
we're gonna we're gonna give you that
experience now oh thank you okay yeah
i'm sorry that you missed out when you
were small
so like the first command here we've got
m1010 and that's saying move to
10 on the x-axis and 10 on the y-axis so
we're going to move our little turtle
and then we're going to draw a line
this is an absolute line so we're going
to draw the line to 30 30.
oh that's exciting there we go
thanks
and then we're going to do a relative
line
and we're going to do relative line
20
units down
excellent yeah so those are like basic
line commands
and we've got some other line commands
that are like shorthand line commands so
h is horizontal line
so we can do
a little horizontal line
what do you think v is i reckon it might
be vertical is it is that right yeah
excellent and it's relative again
because it's lowercase yeah relative
again okay lowercase
cool right don't ask me any questions
[Laughter]
so we're sticking just to cubic beziers
for
this because um
quadratic two there's too many points
it's too confusing um so we're just
gonna stick to like the two
most basic curve commands so
this is just a curve
um and it's got three coordinates the
last one
is the end value that we're going to
and then the first two are the bezier
handle points
right so it's going to do
that
[Music]
you can see that they've got the bezier
handles there so you can imagine if you
move those bezier handle points
the curve would change yep and this is
really cool for animation as well
because once you know what individual
path
points are if you wanted to animate a
certain point of the path you could just
interpolate that particular point very
nicely in order to do that and that's
nice and simple
um so then this is smooth curve two
and smooth curve two is it's really nice
to pair with the curve command because
you get an assumed bezier handle that
reflects the fur the last bezier handle
from the curve
exactly
so this is carrying on from the c one
yeah carries on from the c one and
because it reflects automatically the
first bezier um
curve you get a really nice smooth
continuation whereas it's actually quite
hard to get smooth continuations if you
don't have that you have to do more
maths
i've always just done that manually in
the past but but doing exactly what you
say there so i would have the first
handle would be positive 20 from the
position which is what it's going to
that would be what it does automatically
is automatically yes very nice all right
so
we do that we've got
that's our last little thing
it's very good and our turtle's at our
destination
i feel like i've been to a fancy infant
school
that's that's the vibe i was going for
so yeah just another little bit of fun
um
i used there's a gsap utility um where
you can create a motion path in the in
the browser you can edit it so
um if you're getting your head around
curve like um if you're getting your
head around svg paths and you want to
have a play around you can use this on
codepen and you can just create an
editable path in the browser interesting
and it's it's not just
it's changing the path entirely there
because you can see that the one that's
supposed to be reflected stops being
reflected so it's actually changing the
command and you can save out the path as
well very nice it's just a little fun
thing to play around with
yeah do you feel like you understand svg
plus a little bit more
well there's the infant school thing
which is certainly a plus but yes i do
actually and it's i think probably
because i have written the spg pass
before i think probably the biggest
takeaway which
for me is writing them with line breaks
which i know is such a small thing yeah
like there's so much code i've got in my
projects where i'm not doing that for no
good reason and yeah yeah that even just
like makes it nice and readable makes it
so much more readable
we forgot last time to do introductions
you want to do introductions every time
okay hi
this is http 203 and i'm jake archibald
and sitting alongside me is cassie evans
from off of the green sock
is that good